expliquer le plus clairement
- Depuis presque deux ans,
le même rituel pour se protéger
de l'ennemi invisible.
- I feel better than yesterday.
- Perfect!
So, we will be able, today
even, to sit you in the chair.
- Et depuis des mois,
le même scénario :
un patient non-vacciné foudroyé
par la COVID et soigné à grands
frais aux soins intensifs.
Dr YANICK BEAULIEU, cardiologue
intensiviste, Hôp. Sacré-Coeur
- Les patients très malades :
beaucoup de non-vaccinés
ou des vaccinés immunocompromis.
- Depuis Noël, le nombre
de patients COVID aux soins
intensifs a plus que triplé.
Ils occupent maintenant
21 des 30 lits.
- S'il te reste juste 9 lits
sur 30 pour admettre le reste,
bien, tu fais moins du reste.
Le reste étant des chirurgies
cardiaques, cancers et tout.
- Plus de cas, tellement que
certains médicaments contre
la COVID commencent à manquer.
- Il y a vraiment ce problème-là
qui fait qu'avec le nombre
de cas, il y a beaucoup de
traitements de donnés, puis
on manque de ces médicaments-là.
- Il y a des patients
à plus de 10 jours.
- Un étage plus bas,
la Dre Vicky Soulière participe
à la réunion quotidienne
où l'on cherche des solutions.
- As-tu des lits de libres pour
accueilir des COVID, là aussi?
- Oui.
- D'autres hôpitaux devront
prendre des patients;
Sacré-Coeur approche
du point de saturation.
- Ça fait 2 ans qu'on fait ça.
- Et contrairement aux vagues
précédentes, le problème
ne touche plus seulement
les soins intensifs.
On compte beaucoup plus de
cas bénins, ce qui submerge
d'autres départements,
comme ici, la pneumologie.
Dre VICKY SOULIÈRE, cardiologue,
Hôpital du Sacré-Coeur
- On a commencé par remplir
un peu les chambres du fond.
On les a laissées un peu à part.
Puis, progressivement,
au fur et à mesure que
les patients ont augmenté...
on a fini par, en fait,
remplir le module au complet.
- Une soixantaine de lits
de pneumologie transformés
en lits COVID. On y isole
des patients qui ne sont
pas très malades et qui,
pour la plupart, ont appris
à l'hôpital qu'ils étaient
infectés.
- La moitié des COVID
viennent pas pour la COVID,
ils viennent pour autre chose,
puis on attrape la COVID, fait
qu'on gère pas de la COVID;
on gère des isolements!
C'est un peu... je pense que
c'est la vague de la gestion
des isolements. Des isolements
des patients qui viennent pour
autre chose et l'isolemement
des travailleurs de la santé qui
sont aussi aux prises avec ça.
- Réduire la quarantaine
des travailleurs est
l'une des solutions.
- Ça se peut qu'on puisse
lever l'isolement aujourd'hui.
- On attend aujourd'hui...
- Juste à côté, en cardiologie,
situation semblable. La moitié
des lits sont occupés par des
patients infectés par la COVID.
GEORGES EL KHOURY, infirmier-
chef, Hôpital du Sacré-Coeur
- Présentement : 12 lits de
cas de COVID positifs sur 24.
Donc, c'est vraiment
50 % de notre département
de COVID positifs de
toutes les spécialités.
- Et avec le retour en classe,
la nervosité augmente.
- Beaucoup de travailleurs
de la santé ont des enfants
à l'école aussi, mais on a
un peu la chienne, être honnête,
de...- voir les cas réaugmenter.
- En ce creux de cinquième
vague, difficile de voir
comment on pourra éventuellement
combler le retard accumulé.
- C'est qu'il va falloir
rattraper tout le retard
qu'on a pris, alors qu'on va,
tout le monde, être à plat
un peu, fait que je pense
que... les prochains mois
vont être difficiles, même
une fois la vague passée.
- Ici Davide Gentile,
Radio-Canada, Mo